the following is a conversation with jay
baracaria professor of medicine health
policy and economics at stanford
university
please allow me to say a few words about
lockdowns and the blinding destructive
effects of arrogance on leadership
especially in the space of policy and
politics
jay barakaria is the co-author of the
now famous great barrington declaration
a one-page document that in october 2020
made a case against the effectiveness of
lockdowns
most of this podcast conversation is
about the ideas related to this document
and so let me say a few things here
about what troubles me
those who advocate for lockdowns as a
policy
often ignore the quiet suffering of
millions that it results in which
includes economic pain loss of jobs that
give meaning and pride in the face of
uncertainty the increase in suicide and
suicidal ideation and in general the
fear and anger that arises from the
powerlessness forced onto the populace
but the self-proclaimed elites and
experts
many folks whose job is unaffected by
the lockdowns talk down to the masses
about which path forward is right and
which is wrong
what troubles me most
is this very lack of empathy among the
policymakers for the common man
and in general for people unlike
themselves the landscape of suffering is
vast and must be fully considered in
calculating the response to the pandemic
with humility and with rigorous
open-minded scientific debate
jay and i talk about the email from
francis collins to anthony fauci that
called jay and his two co-authors
fringe epidemiologists and also called
for a devastating published takedown of
their ideas
these words from francis
broke my heart
i understand them i can even steel man
them
but nevertheless on balance they show to
me a failure of leadership
leadership in a pandemic is hard
which is why great leaders are
remembered by history
they are rare they stand out
and they give me hope
also this whole mess
inspires me on my small individual level
to do the right thing
in the face of conformity
despite the long odds
i talked to francis collins i talked to
albert burleigh pfizer ceo
i also talked and will continue to talk
with people like jay
and other dissenting voices that
challenge the mainstream narratives and
those in the seats of power
i hope to highlight both the strengths
and weaknesses in their ideas with
respect and empathy but also with guts
and skill
the skill part i hope to improve on over
time
and i do believe that conversation
and an open mind is the way out of this
and finally as i've said in the past i
value love
and integrity far far above money fame
and power
those latter three are all ephemeral
they slip through the fingers of anyone
who tries to hold on
and leave behind an empty shell of a
human being
i prefer to die a man who lived by
principles that nobody could shake and a
man who added a bit of love to the world
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now here's my
conversation with jay batakaria
to our best understanding today how
deadly is coveted
do we have a good measure
for for this very question
so the the best evidence for covet the
deadline to covet comes from a whole
series of zero prevalent studies sierra
preference studies are these studies of
antibody prevalence in the population at
large
i was
part of the you know the very first set
of sierra problem studies one in santa
clara county one in l.a county and one
in the with major league baseball around
the u.s uh if i may just pause you for a
second
if people don't know what uh serology is
in cerro prevalence it does sound like
you say zero prevalence it's not it's
cerro and serology's antibodies so it's
it's a a survey that counts the number
of antibodies specifically
people that have antibodies
specific to kovaid which perhaps shows
an indication that they likely have had
cobit and therefore this is a way to
study how many people in the population
have been exposed to have had
exactly yeah exactly so the idea is that
uh
we don't know
exactly the number of people with cove
just by counting the people that are
there to present themselves with
symptoms of covid um covet has it turns
out a very wide range of symptoms
possible ranging from no symptoms at all
to this deadly viral pneumonia that's
killed so many people and the problem is
like in if you just count the number of
cases the people who have very few
symptoms so often don't show up for
testing we just don't they're outside of
the can of of public health
and so it's really hard to know that the
answer to your question without
understanding how many people are
infected because you you can probably
tell the number of deaths that's even
though there's some controversy over
that but uh that so that the numerators
is possible but the denominator is much
harder how much controversy is there
about the death we're gonna go on
million tangents is that okay we're
gonna i have a million questions so one
i love data so much
but i've like almost tuned out paying
attention to cover data because i feel
like i'm walking on shaky ground i don't
know who to trust
um maybe you can comment on different
sources of data different kinds of data
the death one that seems like a really
important one
can we trust the reported deaths
associated with covid or is it just a
giant messy thing that mixed up and then
there's this kind of stories about
hospitals being incentivized
uh to report a death as covert death so
uh uh there's some truth in some of that
let me just so
let me just talk about the incentive so
in the united states
we passed this cares act that was aimed
at
making sure hospital assistance didn't
go bankrupt in the early days the
pandemic
the couple things they did one was they
provided incentives to treat covet
patients
tens of thousands of dollars extra per
per covered patient
um and the other thing they did is they
they gave a 20 bump to medicare payments
for elderly patients who are treated
with covet the idea is that there's more
expensive to treat them i guess the
early days um so that did provide an
incentive to sort of have have a lot of
code patients in the hospital because
your financial
success of the hospital or at least not
by the lack of financial ruin depended
on having many covered patients the
other thing on the death certificates is
that reporting of deaths is a separate
issue i don't know that there's a
financial incentive there but there is
this sort of like complicated you know
when you fill out a death certificate
for a patient with a lot of conditions
uh like let's say a patient has diabetes
a patient that well that diabetes could
lead to
heart failure you know you have a heart
attack heart failure your lungs fill up
then you get covered and
what and you die so what do you what do
you write on the death certificate was
it cause it covered the killed you was
it the lungs filling up was it the the
heart heart failure was it the diabetes
it's really difficult to like
disentangle
um and i think a lot of a lot of times
what's happened is they people have like
erred on the side of signing is covet
now what's the evidence of this there's
been a couple of
of audits of death certificates in
places like santa clara county where i
live in alameda county
uh california where they they carefully
went through the death certificate said
okay is this reasonable to say this was
actually covered or is it was covered
incidental and they found that about 25
20 25 of the deaths were
more likely incidental than directly due
to covet
i i personally don't get too excited
about this i mean it's a philosophical
question right like ultimately
what kills you
it's which is an odd thing to say if you
if you're if you're not you're not in
medicine but like really it's it's a
it's almost always multifactorial it's
always always just the bus hits you the
bus hits you that you get a brain bleed
was the brain bleed that killed you
would it burst anyway i mean you know
the bus hits you killed you right the
way you die is a philosophical question
but it's also a sociological and
psychological question because it seems
like
every single person who's passed away
over the past couple of years kind of
the first question that comes to mind is
just was it not not just because you're
trying to be political but just in your
mind no i think there's a psychological
reason for this right so um
you know we have we spent uh the better
part of a at least a half century in the
united states not worried too much
about infectious diseases and we the
notion was we'd essentially conquered
them it was something that happens in
faraway places to other people
and that's true for much of the
developed world life expectancies were
going up
for you know decades and decades
and for the first time in living memory
we have a disease that can kill us
i mean i think we're effectively evolved
to fear that like the the panic centers
of our brain the lizard part of our
brain takes over
and our central focus has been avoiding
this one risk
um and so it's not surprising that but
people when they're filling out death
certificates or thinking about what what
led to the death
this most salient thing that's in the
front of everyone's brain would jump to
the top
and we can't ignore
this very deep psychological thing when
we consider
what people say on the internet what
people say to each other what people
write in scientific papers what
everything it feels like
when covid
has been
um
has been brought onto this world
everything changed in the way people
feel about each other just the way they
communicate with each other i think
the the level of emotion involved
i think it in many people it brought out
the worst in them
for sometimes short periods of time and
sometimes it was always therapeutic like
you were waiting to get out like the
darkest parts of you
just to say if you're angry at something
in this world i'm going to say it now
and um i think that's probably talking
to some deep primal thing that
um
fear we have for um
formalities of all different kinds and
then when that fear is aroused and all
the deepest emotions it's like a
freudian
uh psychotherapy session but across the
world something that uh psychologists
are gonna have a field day with for
generation trying to understand um i
mean i think that
i mean what you say is right but piled
on top of that is also this sort of
uh this impetus to empathy to empathize
compassion toward others
essentially militarized
right so i'm protecting you by by some
actions
and
uh those actions if i if i don't do them
if you don't do them well that months
must mean you don't just you you hate me
um it's created this like social tension
that i've never seen before and we and
we start have started we started we
looked at each other as if we were just
simply
sources of of germs
rather than people to get to know
people to enjoy people to get you know
to learn from um it it colored
basically almost every human interaction
for every every human on the planet
yeah the basic common humanity it's like
you can wear a mask you can stand far
away
but the
love you have for each other when you
look into each other's eyes that was
dissipating and
by region too i've experienced having
traveled quite a bit throughout this
time
it um it was really sad even people that
are really close together just the way
they stood the way they looked at each
other
and i it made me feel for a moment
um
that the fabric that connects all of us
is more fragile than i thought
i mean if you walk down the street or if
you ever if you did this during covet
i'm sure you had this experience where
you walk down the street if you're not
wearing a mask or even if you are
people will jump off the off the
sidewalk as you walk past them
as if your poison
even though the data are that covet
spreads you know indifferently outdoors
or if at all really at outdoors
but it's not simply a biological or
infectious disease phenomenon or
immunological it's it is a it is a it's
a
it is a change in the way humans treated
each other i hope hope temporary
i do want to say on the flip side of
that so i was
mostly in boston massachusetts when the
pandemic broke out i think that's where
i was yeah
and then i got came here to austin texas
to visit my now good friend joe rogan
and he was the first person
without pause this wasn't a political
statement this was anything just walk
toward me and give me a big hug
and say it's great to see you and i
can't tell you how great it felt because
i in that moment realized the absence of
that connection back in boston over just
a couple of over a couple of months and
um
it's we'll talk about it more but it's
tragic to think about
that distancing that dissolution of
common humanity at scale what what kind
of impact it has on society just
across the board political division
uh and just in the quiet of your own
mind in the privacy of your own home the
depression the sadness the loneliness
that leads to suicide
and forget suicide just
low key suffering yeah no i think that's
that's the suffering that isolation
we're not meant to live alone we're not
meant to live apart from one another
that's of course the ideology of
lockdown is to make people live apart
alone isolated so that we don't spread
diseases to each other right
but we're not actually designed as a
species to live that way
and that uh what you're describing i
think
if everyone's honest with themselves
have felt uh especially in places where
that where lockdowns have been sort of
very militantly enforced has felt deep
into their core
well i if i could just return to the
question of deaths he said that the data
isn't perfect because we need these kind
of serial prevalence surveys to
understand how many cases there were to
determine the rate of deaths
and we need to have a strong footing in
the number of deaths but if we assume
that the the
the number of deaths is approximately
correct
like what's your sense what kind of
statements
can we say about the deadliness of covet
against
across different demographics maybe not
in a political way or in the current way
but when history looks back
at this moment of time
50 years from now 100 years from now the
way we look at the
pandemic 100 years ago
what will they say about the deadliness
of code i mean i think the deadlines of
kova depends on not just the virus
itself but who who it infects
um so the probably the most important
thing about it about the deadlines of
covet is is this steep age gradient in
the mortality rate um so according to
these zero prevalence studies that that
that have been done now hundreds of them
um
mostly from before vaccination because
vaccination also reduces the mortality
risk of covid um the the sierra
prevalent studies suggest that
the risk of of death if you're say over
the age of 70
is
very high if you have five percent
if you get covered
if you're if you're under the age of 70
it's lower
0.05 but there's not a single sharp cut
off it's more like i have a rule of
thumb that i use um so if you're 50
say the infection fatality rate from
covalent is 0.2
according to the zero prevalence data
that means 99.8 survival
if you're 50 and for every seven years
of age above that double it every seven
years of age below that have it
so 57 year old have a 0.4
mortality a 64 year old would have a
point eight percent and so on and uh if
you have a severe chronic disease like
diabetes or if you're more morbidly
obese it's like adding seven seven years
to your life
and this is uh for unvaccinated folks
this is unvaccinated uh in the before
delta also
are there a lot of people that will be
listening to this with phds at the end
of their name that would disagree with
the 99.8 would you say so i think
there's some disagreement over this uh
and the disagreement
is about the quality of the zero
prevalence studies that were conducted
so as i said earlier i was the senior
investigator in three different sierra
problem studies and very early in the
epidemic
i view them as very high quality studies
um we we um in santa clara county what
we did is we used a a test kit
uh to uh that we obtained
from uh someone who was works in major
league baseball actually he ordered
these test kits very early in march 2020
that measures very accurately measures
antibody levels
antibodies in the in in the bloodstream
uh these test kits were eventually were
approved by the the head of eua by the
emergency use authorization by the fda
sort of shortly after we did this
and uh it had a very low false positive
rate false plot of means if you if you
uh if you don't have these coveted
antibodies in your bloodstream the cut
kit shows up positive anyways that that
turns out to happen about point five
percent of the time
um and uh based on studies a very large
number of studies looking at
blood from 2018 you try it against this
kit
and uh you know point five percent of
the time 2018 there shouldn't be any
bodies there so for to cover if it turns
positive as a false positive 0.5 of the
time
um and then you know like a false
negative rate about 10
12 something like that i don't remember
the exact number but the false positive
rate is the important thing there right
so you have a population in march 2020
or april 2020 with very low
fraction of patients having been exposed
to code you don't know how much but low
even a small false positive rate could
end up
biasing your study quite a bit
but there's a formula to adjust for that
you can adjust for the fourth spot rate
falls negative rate we did we did that
adjustment and those studies found in a
community population so leaving aside
people in nursing homes who have a
higher death rate from covid um the that
the death rate was point two percent in
santa clara county
and in l.a county across all these
groups in the community community
meaning just like regular yeah so like
that that's actually a real important
question too so uh the santa clara study
we did this facebook sampling scheme
um which is i mean not not the ideal
thing but just like it was very
difficult to get a random sample on and
during the you know during lockdown
um where we put out uh an ad on facebook
soliciting people to
volunteer for the study a randomly
selected set of people we were hoping to
get a random selection of people from
santa clara county but it tended to the
people who tend to volunteer were from
the richer parts of the county like i
had
stanford professors writing begging to
be in the study because they wanted
antibody levels so we did some
adjustment for that in la county we
hired a firm that had a pre-existing
representative sample of la county
um
so but it didn't include nursing homes
it didn't include people in jail things
like that didn't include the homeless
populations so it's it's representative
of a community dwelling population
both of those and there we found that
both in l.a county and santa clara
county in april 2020 something like 40
to 50 times more infections than cases
in both places
so for every case that had been reported
to the public health authorities we
found that you know you know 40 or 50
other infections people with antibodies
in their blood
that suggested that they'd had coveted
recovered so people were not reporting
or severe at least in those days under
reporting yeah i mean there was you know
there's testing problems there weren't
so many tests available people didn't
know a lot of a lot of them we asked a
set of questions about the symptoms
they've faced
and most of them said they faced no
symptoms or the most uh 30 40 of them
said face their no symptoms
and i mean even these days how many
people report that they get covered when
they get covered okay i'll have those
numbers
that point two percent has that
approximately held up over time that is
so if professor john ian edis who's a
colleague of mine at stanford uh is a
world expert in meta analysis probably
the most cited scientist on earth i
think uh at least living
he he did a a meta-analysis of now a
hundred or more of these cereal
prevalence studies
um and uh uh what he found was that that
point two percent is roughly the
worldwide number in fact i think he
cites this lower number 0.15 percent
as the median infection fatality rate
worldwide
so we did these studies and it generated
an enormous amount of blowback
by people who thought that the infection
rate is much higher
and there's some controversy over the
quality of some of the other studies
that that are done and so there are some
people who look at this same literature
and say well the the lower quality
studies tend to have lower ifrs
the higher quality studies how far oh
infection fatality right i apologize i
do this in lectures too
and i'm going to rudely interrupt you
and ask for uh for the basics sometimes
if it's okay no of course so these these
higher quality studies they say are tend
to produce higher but the problem is
that if you want a global eye infection
fatality rate you need to get
sierra problem studies from everywhere
even places that don't necessarily have
the infrastructure set up to produce
very very high quality studies
and in poor places in the world
this the the st that uh like places like
africa the infection fatality rate is
incredibly low
uh and in some richer places
like new york city the infection
fatality rate is is much higher
it's there's a range of ifrs not a
single number
this sometimes surprises people because
they think well it's a it's a virus it
should have the same properties no
matter where it goes
but the virus
kills or infects or hurts in interaction
with the host
and the properties of both the host and
the virus
combine to produce the the outcome but
you also mentioned the environment too
well it's i'm thinking mainly just about
the the person like if i'm gonna think
about it like the most simplest way to
think about it is age age is the single
most important risk factor
so older places are going to have a
higher ifr
than younger places africa three percent
of africa is over 65. so in some sense
it's not surprising that they have a low
infection fatality rate so that's one
way you would explain the difference
between africa and new york city in
terms of the fatality rate is the age
the average age yeah and especially in
the early days of the epidemic in new
york city
the
uh
older populations living in nursing
homes were differentially infected
based on because of policies that were
adopted right to send
coveted infected patients back to
nursing homes to keep hospitals empty
what do you mean by differentially
infected
the policy that you adopt determines who
is most exposed right that okay so
that's what the policy it's the person
that matters
i mean it's not like the virus just kind
of it doesn't care i mean the policy
determines the nature of the interaction
and there's also i mean there is some
contribution from the
environment different regions have
different proximity maybe of people
interacting or the dynamics of the way
they interact
like if you have a if you have
situations where there's lots of
intergenerational
uh interactions yeah then you have a
very different risk profile than if than
if you have societies that are where
generations are more separate from one
another
um
okay so let me just finish real fast
about this so you you have in new york
you have a population that was infected
in the early days that was
very likely going to die but had a much
higher likelihood of dying if infected
and so new york city had a higher ifr
especially in the early days than um
than um then like africa has had
um the other thing is treatment right so
the treatments that we adopted in the
early days the epidemic i think actually
may have exacerbated the risk of death
which do so like
using ventilators like the the over
reliance on ventilators is what i'm
primarily thinking of but i can think of
other things
um but that that uh also we've learned
over time how better to manage patients
with the disease
so you have those you have all those
things combined so that's that's where
the controversy over this over this
number is i mean
new york city
also it has a is a central hub for those
who tweet
and uh those who write powerful stories
and narratives in article form
and i remember those quite dramatic
stories about sort of doctors in the
hospitals and these kinds of things i
mean there's very serious very dramatic
very tragic deaths going on always in
hospitals those stories
um
a lot of loved ones losing each other on
a deathbed that's always tragic and you
can always write a hell of a good story
about that and you should about the loss
of loved ones but they were doing it
pretty pretty well i would say um over
this kind of dramatic deaths and so in
response to that it's very
unpleasant to hear even to consider the
possibility that
the death rate is not as high as you
might otherwise as you might feel yeah i
was surprised by the reaction
both by regular people and also the
scientific community in response to
those studies those early studies in
april of 2020 um uh to me they uh they
were there were studies i mean they're
they're the kinds of not exactly the
kinds of work i've worked on all my life
but it's kind of kind of like the kind
of you know like you you write a paper
and you get response responses from your
fellow scientists and you you know
change the paper to improve it uh you
have hopefully learned something from it
well but to push back it's just a study
but there's some studies and this is
kind of interesting because i've
received similar pushback on other
topics
there's
some studies that
if
wrong might have a wide ranging uh
detrimental effects on society so that's
that that's the way they would perceive
the studies if you say the death rate is
lower and you end up as you often do in
science realizing that nope that that
was there was a flaw in the way the
study was conducted or were just not
representative of a broader population
and then you realize the death rate is
much higher that might be very damaging
in in people's view uh so so that's
probably
where the scientific community sort of
just steal man the kind of response is
that's where they felt like you know
there's some findings where you better
be damn sure before you kind of report
them
yeah i mean we were pretty sure we were
right and it turns out we were right so
like when we so um
we released the the santa clara study
via this open open science process and
this uh server called med med archive
it's it's designed for releasing studies
have not yet been pre-reviewed in order
to garner comment from the from
scientists before peer review
the the la county study we went through
the traditional peer review process
and got it published in the journal of
american medical association sometime in
like uh july i think forget the date of
2020.
the santa clara study released in april
of 2020 in this you know sort of working
paper archive
the the reason was that we felt we had
an obligation we had a result that was
we thought was quite important
and we wanted to tell the scientific
community about it and also tell the
world about it
and it wasn't we wanted to get feedback
i mean that's part of the purpose of
sending it to these kinds of places
i think a lot of the problem is that
uh when people think about published
science they think of it as
automatically true and if it goes
through peer review it's automatically
true if it hasn't gone through peer
review it's not automatically true and
especially in medicine when we're not
used to having this at this access to
pre-peer-reviewed
work i mean in economics actually that's
quite normal you it takes years to get
something published so there's a very
active debate over or discussion about
papers before they're peer-reviewed in
this in this sort of working paper way
um much less normal or much much newer
in in medicine
and so i think part of that the
perception about what those that what
process happens in open science when you
release a study
that that got people confused and you're
right it was a very important result
because we had just locked the world
down in middle of march
with i think catastrophic results
and if the if that study was right if
our study was right that meant we'd made
a mistake
and not because the death rate was low
that's actually not the key thing there
the key thing is that we had adopted
these policies these test and trace
policies these policies these lockdown
policies aimed at suppressing the virus
level to close to zero that was
essentially the idea
if we can just get the virus to go away
we won't have to ever worry about it
again
the main problem with our result as far
as that strategy was concerned wasn't
the death rate it was the 40 to 50 times
more infections than cases it was the
two and a half percent or uh three
percent or four percent prevalence rate
that we identified
of the antibodies in the population if
that number is right it's too late the
virus is not going to go to zero
and no matter how much we test and trace
and isolate we're not going to get the
viral level down to zero
so we're going to have to
let the virus go through the entire
population in some way or something
normal well that we can talk about that
in a bit that's the great barrington
declaration you don't have to let the
virus go through the population you can
shield preferentially
the policy we chose was to shield
preferentially the the laptop class
the set of people who could work from
home
without losing their job
yeah and we did a very good job at
protecting them well let me um
take a small tangent we're gonna jump
around in time
which i think will be the best way to
tell the story so that was the beginning
yeah okay actually can i kind of go back
one more thing for that because that's
really important and i should have i
should have started with this
um what led me to do those studies
was a a paper that i had remembered
seeing from the h1n1 flu epidemic in
2009 this is this is where i've been
much less active in writing about that i
had written up like a paper or two about
that when in 2009
there there was actually this same
debate over the mortality rate
except it unfolded over the course of
three years two or three years
the early studies
of the mortality rate
in h1n1 counted the number of cases
in the denominator count the number of
deaths in the numerator cases meaning
people identified as having h1n1 showing
up the doctor
you know tested to have it um and the
early estimates of the h1n1 mortality
were like four percent three percent
really really high
over the course of a couple of more
years a whole bunch of zero prevalence
studies zero prevalence studies of h1n1
flu came out
and it turned out that there were
a hundred or more times of people
infected per case
and so the mortality rate was actually
something like 0.02
for h1n1 not the three three
like a hundredfold difference so this
made you think
okay it took us a couple of two to three
years to discover the truth behind the
actual infections
uh for a h1n1 and then
what's the truth here and can we get
there faster yeah and and there was it
spreads in a similar way as the as the
h1n1 fluid did i mean it's it's spreads
very solidization via you know so
person-to-person breathing kind of kind
of contact up um and maybe maybe some by
by foam eyes but it seems like that's
less likely now in any case it seemed
really important to me to speed up the
process of having those zero prevalence
studies
so that we can better understand who was
at risk
and what the right strategy ought to be
this might be a good place to kind of
compare influenza
the flu and covid in the context of the
discussion we just had which is
how deadly is coved so you mentioned
covet is a very particular kind of
steepness
where the x-axis is age
so
in that context could you maybe compare
influenza and kovid because a lot of
people
outside the folks who suggest that the
the lizards who run the world have
completely fabricated invented kovid
outside of those folks kind of the
natural
process by which you dismiss the threat
of covait to say well it's just like the
flu the flu is a very serious thing
actually um so
in that comparison
where does kovitz stand
yeah the flu is a very serious thing it
kills you know 50 60 000 people a year
something i found that order depending
on the the particular strain that goes
around uh that's in the united states
the primary difference to me are the
there's lots of differences but one of
the most salient differences is the age
gradient and mortality risk for the flu
so the flu is more deadly for two
children than covet is
there's no controversy about that
children thank god
have much less
uh severe
reactions to covet infection to than
that due to flu infections and rate of
fatalities fatality all of that i think
you mentioned um
i mean it's interesting to maybe also
comment on i think in another
conversation mentioned there's a u
shape
to the
to the flu curve
so meaning like there's actually quite a
large number of kids that die from flu
yeah i mean the 1918 flu the h1n1 flew
that the spanish flu in the us killed
millions of of of uh of younger people
and um that is not the case with covid
more than um
i'm going to get the number wrong but
something like 70 80 percent of the
deaths are people over the age of 60.
well we've talked about the fear the
whole time really
but my interaction with folks
now i want to have a family i want to
have kids but i don't have that real
firsthand experience but my interaction
with folks is at the core of fear
that folks had
is for their children
like
that
somehow you know i don't want to get
infected because of the kids like
because god forbid something happens to
the kids and i think
that obviously that makes a lot of sense
this kind of
the kids come first no matter what
that's number one priority but in for
this particular virus
that reasoning was um
not grounded in data it seems like or
that emotion and feeling yeah it was not
grounded it wasn't at the same time this
is way more deadly than the flu just
overall and especially to older people
yes
right so the numbers when when the story
is
all said and done
the covet would take
many more lives yeah
so i mean 0.2 is sounds like a small
number but it's not a small number
worldwide what do you think that number
will be
by the you know that's not that's not
like but would we cross i think it's in
the united states it's uh
the way the desk currently reports like
800 000 something like that do you think
we'll cross a million seems likely
yeah do you think it's something that
might continue with different variants
what well i i think um so we can talk
about the end state of cover the end
state of covet is it's here forever
i think that there is good evidence of
immunity after infection
such that you're protected both against
reinfection and also against severe
disease upon reinfection
so the second time you get it it's not
true for everyone but for many people
the second time you get it will be
milder much milder than the first time
you get it with the long tail like uh
that lasts for a long time yeah so just
there's studies that uh that follow of
course people who are infected for a
year
and the reinfection rate is something
like somewhere between point three and
one percent yeah um and like a pretty
fantastic study italy's found that
there's there was one in sweden i think
there's a few studies that found there's
some similar things um and the
reinfections
tend to produce much mild disease much
less likely end up in the hospital much
less likely to die um so what the end
state of covid is it's circulating the
population forever and you get it
multiple times
yeah
and and then there's
i think studies and discussions like the
the best protection would be to get it
and then also to get vaccinated and then
a lot of people push back against that
for the obvious reasons from both sides
because somehow this the discourse has
become less scientific and more
political well i think you wanna like
the first time you meet it is going to
be the most deadly for you
and so the first time you meet it is
wise to be vaccinated the vaccine
reduces severe disease
yeah well we'll talk about the vaccine
because i want to make sure i address it
carefully
and properly in full context
um
but yes sort of uh to add to the context
a lot of the fascinating discussions
we're having is um in the early days of
covid and now for people who are
unvaccinated that's where the
interesting story is
the policy story the sociology
sociological story and so on but
let me go to something really
fascinating just because of the people
involved the human beings evolved and
because of how deeply i care about
science and also kindness respect and
love and human things
francis collins wrote a letter in
october 2020
to anthony fauci anything somebody else
i have um
the letter oh it's not a letter email i
apologize
uh hi tony and cliff
c
gb declaration.org
this proposal
this is the great barrington declaration
that you're a co-author on this proposal
from the three fringe epidemiologists
who met with the secretary seem to be
getting a lot of attention and even a
co-signature from nobel prize winner
mike levitt at stanford
there needs to be a quick and
devastating published takedown
of its premises
i don't see anything like that online
yet is it underway question mark francis
francis collins director of the nih
somebody i talked to on this podcast
recently
okay
a million questions i want to ask but
first how did that make you feel when
you first
saw this uh email come to uh
uh too light which when when when did it
come to light uh this week actually i
think or last week okay so this is
because of freedom of information yeah
which by the way
sort of um
maybe because i do want to add positive
stuff on the on the side of francis here
um
boy when i see stuff like that i wonder
if all my emails leaked
how much embarrassing stuff like i think
i'm a good person
but i don't
i haven't read my old emails maybe i'm
pretty sure sometimes later i could be
an [ __ ]
well i mean look he's a christian and
i'm a christian i'm supposed to forgive
right i mean i think
he was looking at this
great barrington declaration as a
political problem to be solved
as opposed to a serious alternative
approach to the epidemic
so maybe we'll talk about in more detail
but just for in case people are not
familiar great barrington declaration
was
was was the document
that you co-authored
that basically argues against this idea
of lock down as a solution to covid and
you propose another solution that we'll
talk about but the point is
it's not
that dramatic of a document
it is just a document that criticizes
one policy solution that was but it was
the policy solution that had been put
forward by
dr collins and by tony fauci
and a few other few other science not i
mean i think a relatively small number
of scientists and epidemiologists in
charge of
the advice given to governments
worldwide
and it was a challenge to that policy
that said that look there there is an
alternate path that that the path we've
chosen this path of lock down with an
aim to suppress the virus to zero
effectively i mean that was unstated um
cannot work and is causing catastrophic
harm to
large numbers of poor and vulnerable
people worldwide
we put this out in october 4th i think
of 2020
and
it went viral i mean i've never actually
been involved with anything like like
this where i just put the document on
the web
and tens of thousands of doctors signed
on hundreds of thousands of regular
people signed on
it it really struck a accord of uh
people because i think even by october
of 2020 people had this sense that there
was something really wrong
with the coveted policy that we've been
following
and they were looking for
reasonable people to give an alternative
i mean we're not arguing that covet
doesn't isn't a serious thing i mean it
is a very serious thing this is why we
we had a policy that aimed at addressing
it
um
we were but we were saying that the
policy we're following is not the right
one
so how does a democratic
uh government deal with that challenge
uh so to me that you asked me how i felt
i was actually frankly just i was i i
suspected there had been some email
exchanges like that not necessarily from
francis collins
around the government around this
time i mean i felt the full brunt of a
propaganda campaign
almost immediately after we published it
where newspapers mischaracterized it in
all in the same the same way over and
over and over again
and sought to
characterize me as sort of of a as a
sort of a marginal fringe figure or
whatnot and me and sinatra grouped uh
martin culdor for the tens of thousands
of other people that signed it
i felt the brunt of that
all year long
so to see this in black and white in you
know with the handwriting essentially if
i mean the the metaphorical handwriting
of francis collins was actually frankly
a disappointment because i i've looked
up to him for years
yeah i've looked up them as well
i um
i mean i look for the the best in people
and
i still look up to him
what troubles me is several things
the reason i said about the
the [ __ ] emails that i send late at
night
is um
i can understand this email
it's fear it's panic not being sure
the fringe three fringe epidemiologists
plus mike levitt who won a nobel prize i
mean but using fringe
maybe in my private thoughts i have said
things like that about others
like a little bit too unkind like you
don't really mean it
now add to that
he
recently this week whatever
uh
double down on the fringe
this is really troubling to me
that like i can excuse this email but
to see the arrogance there
i that francis honestly i mean
broke my heart a little bit there this
was an opportunity to like especially at
this stage
to say
just like i told him um
to say i was wrong to use those words in
that email
i was i was wrong to not be open to
ideas
i still believe that this is not like
say
like actually argue with the with the
proposed with the policy of the proposed
uh solution also
the devastating publish take devastating
takedown
devastating takedown as you say
somebody who's sitting
on billions of dollars that they're
giving to
scientists
some of whom are often not their best
human beings because they're fighting
with each other over money not being
cognizant of the fact that you're
challenging the integrity you're
corrupting the integrity of scientists
by allocating the money
you're now playing with that
by saying devastating takedown
where do you think the published
takedown will come from
it will come from those scientists to
whom you're giving money what kind of
example would they give to the academic
community that thrives on freedom like
this this is
i believe francis collins is a great man
one of the things i was troubled by is
the negative response to him from people
that don't understand the positive
impact that nih has had on society how
many people has helped but this is
exactly the so he's not just a scientist
he's not just a bureaucrat who
distributes money he's also a scientific
leader
that in the time in difficult times we
live in is supposed to inspire us with
trust with love with the freedom of
thought he's supposed to you know those
fringe epidemiologists those are the
heroes of science when you look at the
long arc of history we love those people
we love ideas even when they get proven
wrong that's what always that attracted
me to science like some somebody like
the the lone voice saying oh no the the
the moon of jupiter does move
yeah i mean you know but the funny thing
is you know galileo is saying something
truly revolutionary we were saying
that what we proposed in the great
britain declaration was actually just
the old pandemic plan
it wasn't anything really
fundamentally novel
in fact there were
plans like this that
lockdown scientists had written in late
february early march of 2020. so we were
not saying anything radical we were just
calling for a debate
effectively over the existing lockdown
policy
um and this is a disappointment a really
truly a big disappointment because
by doing this
you were absolutely right lex he sent a
signal
to so many other scientists to just stay
silent even if you had reservations
yeah devastating takedown the people you
know how many people wrote to me
privately like stanford mit
how amazing
the conversation with francis collins
was
there's a kind of admiration because
okay how do i put it um
a lot of people
get into science because they want to
help the world
they get excited by the ideas and they
and they they really are working hard to
help in whatever the discipline is and
then there is sources of funding
which help you do help at a larger scale
so you admire those the people that uh
um
are distributing the money because
they're often
at least on the surface are really also
good people oftentimes they're great
scientists so like it's amazing i that's
why i'm sort of um
like sometimes people from outside think
academia is broken some kind of way no
it's it's a beautiful thing it's a it's
really is a beautiful thing and that's
why it's so deeply heartbreaking where
this person
um
is um i don't think this is malevolence
i think he's just incompetence of
communication
twice i think there's there's also
arrogance at the bottom of it too so
like but you know all of us have
arrogance yeah there's a particular kind
of arrogance right so here it's it's of
the same kind of arrogance that you see
when tony fauci gets on tv and says that
uh that if you criticize me you're not
simply criticizing a man you're
criticizing science itself right right
that is at the heart also of this email
this so the certainty
that the policies that they were
recommending collins and fauci were
recommending to the president of the
united states were right not just right
but right so so far right that any
challenge whatsoever to it is dangerous
um and i think that that is really the
heart of that email it's it's um it's
this idea that
my position is unchallengeable
not to be to be complete to be as
charitable as i can be to this you know
i believe they thought that i believe
they some of them still think that that
that there was only one true policy
possible in response to copenhagen every
other policy was immoral
and if you if you come from that
position then you write an email like
that you go on tv you say effectively
right i mean that that is that is what
happens when you have this sort of
unchallengeable arrogance that the
policy you're following is correct
um i mean when we wrote the great bank
declaration
what i was hoping for
was a discussion
about how to protect the vulnerable i
mean that was the key idea to me in the
whole thing was
better protection of the older
population who really at really serious
risk if infected with covid and we had
been doing a very poor job i thought to
date in many places in protecting the
vulnerable
and what i wanted was a discussion by
local public health
about better methods better policies to
protect the vulnerable
so when when i was when we were met with
instead a series of essentially
propagandist lies about it so they for
instance i kept hearing from reporters
in in those days why do you want to let
the virus rip let it rip let it rip the
words let it rip
does not appear in the great barrington
declaration
the goal isn't to let the virus rip um
the goal is to protect the vulnerable
to let society go as you know open
schools and do other things that it
functions as best it can in the midst of
a terrible pandemic yes
but not let the virus rip
where no the most vulnerable are
protected the goal was to protect the
vulnerable so why let it rip because it
was a propaganda term to hit the fear
centers of people's brains oh these
people are immoral they just want to let
the virus go through society and hurt
everybody that was that was that was the
idea this it was a way to preclude a
discussion and preclude a debate about
the existing policy
so i've uh
this is an app called clubhouse
um i've gone back on it recently
uh to practice russian unrelated for for
a few big russian conversations coming
up anyway it's a great way to talk to
regular people in russian but i also
there was a i was i was nervous i was
preparing for a pfizer ceo conversation
and there was a vaccine room and so i
joined it
and there's a there's a pro science room
as they they these are like scientists
that were calling each other pro science
it the whole thing was like theater to
me i mean i haven't thoroughly
researched but looking at the resume
they were like
pretty solid um
researchers and doctors
and they were mocking
everybody
who was at all i mean it doesn't matter
what they stood for but they were just
mocking people and the arrogance was
overwhelming i had to shut off
because i couldn't handle that human
beings can be like this to each other
and then i i went back to just a double
check is this really how many people are
here is this theater and then i uh asked
to come on stage on clubhouse to make a
couple comments and then as i open my
mouth and say thank you so much you know
this is this is a great room sort of the
usual civil politeness all that kind of
stuff
and
i said i'm worried that
the kind of arrogance with which
things are being discussed here
will further divide us not
unite us and and before
i said even the united further divide us
i was thrown off stage now this isn't
why i mentioned platform but like i am
like uh lex friedman mit
uh also which is something those people
seem to sometimes care about the
followers and stuff like that like did
you just do that and then they said
enough of that nonsense
enough of that nonsense they said to me
enough of that nonsense
somebody who is obviously interviewed
francis collins
is uh uh the pfizer ceo uh you're
bringing a potential epidemiologist also
so just yeah exactly but this broke my
heart the arrogance and this is echoes
of that arrogance is something you see
in this email and i really would love to
have a million things to talk about to
try to figure out how can we find a path
forward i think a lot of
a lot of the problems
we've seen in the
the discussion over cove especially in
the scientific community
you know there's there's two ways to
look at science i think uh that that
have been competing with each other for
a while now
one way and this is the way that i view
science and why i've always found it so
attractive
is an invitation to a structured
discussion
where
the the discussion is tempered by by
evidence by data by by reasoning and
logic
right so it's a dialectical process
where if i believe a and you believe b
well uh we talk about it we come up with
an experiment that distinguishes between
the two and while you know b turns out
to be right i'm i'm all frustrated but i
buy you dinner and i say no no no c and
then we go on from there right that's
that's what science is at its best it's
this process of using data in discussion
it's a human activity right uh to to to
learn
to let have the truth unfold itself
before us
on the other hand there are
there's another way that people have
used science or thought about science as
a as truth in and of itself
right this like if it's if it's science
therefore it's true automatically and
they're
you know what does the science say to do
well the science never says to do
anything the science says here's what's
true and then we have to
apply our human values
to say okay well if we do this well then
this is likely to happen that's what the
science says if we do that then that is
likely to happen well we'd rather have
this than that right and but it doesn't
science doesn't tell us that we'd rather
have this than that is there human
values that tell us that we'd rather
this and that science plays a role but
it's not the only thing
uh it's not the only role it's like it
helps us understand the constraints we
face but it doesn't tell us what to do
in face of those constraints
but underneath it at the individual
level at the institutional level it
seems like
um
arrogance
is really destructive so the flip side
of that the productive thing is humility
so sort of um
always not being
sure that you're right
this is actually kind of uh
stuart russell talks about this for ai
research how do you make sure that ai
super intelligent ai doesn't destroy us
you built in um
a sort of module within it that it
always doubts
its actions like it's not sure
like i know it says i'm supposed to
destroy all humans but maybe i'm wrong
and that maybe i'm wrong is essential
for progress for actually doing in the
long arc of history better not the
perfect thing but better and better and
better and better i mean the the
question i have here for you is
this
this email so clearly captures some
maybe echo but maybe a core to the
problem do you put responsibility of
this email of the shortcomings
and failures on individuals or
institutions
no this is an institutional failure
right so um the nih i so i've had two
decades of nih funding i've sat on nih
review panels the purpose of the nih is
what you said earlier lex the purpose of
nih is to support the work of scientists
to some extent it's also how to help
scientists to direct scientists to work
on things that are very important for
public health or for the health of the
public
um so and the way you do that is you say
okay we're gonna put
you know 50 million dollars on uh the
research in alzheimer's disease this
year or 70 million dollars on hiv or
whatever it is right some and uh that
pot of money then uh scientists compete
with each other for the best ideas to to
use it to address that that problem so
it's essentially an endeavor to support
the work of scientists it is not in and
of itself a policy organ
it doesn't say what public health policy
should be
for that you have the cdc
and
what happened during the pandemic is
that
people
in the nih were called upon
to contribute to public health making
and that created the conflict of
interest you see in that email
right so now you have the head of the
nih
in effect saying to all scientists you
must agree with me
in the policies that i've recommended
or else you're fringe
that is a deep conflict of interest it's
deep because first he he's conflicted he
has this dual role as
as as the head of the nih
supporter of scientific funding and then
also
inappropriately called to set or help
set
pandemic policy
that should never have happened there
should be a bright line between those
two roles
let me ask you about just francis
collins i don't know if you i i had a
chance to talk to him on a podcast i
don't know if you maybe by chance gotten
a chance to hear a few words of it
um well i have a kind of a question uh
to that because a lot of people
wrote to me quite negative things about
francis collins and like i said i still
believe
he's a great man a great scientist
um
one of the things when i
talked to him off mike
about the vaccine
the excitement he had about when we were
recollecting when they first got an
inkling that it's actually going to be
possible to get a vaccine
just he wasn't messaging just in the
private or of our own conversation he
was really excited and why was he
excited because he gets to help a lot of
people this is a man
that really wants to help people and
there could be some institutional
self-delusion the arrogance all those
kinds of things that lead to this kind
of email but ultimately the the goal is
this is what i don't think people quite
realize this
the reason you call your fringe
epidemiologist the reason there needs to
be a devastating uh published takedown
he i believe really believes
that this it could be very dangerous
yeah and
it's a lot of burden to carry on his
shoulders because like you said in his
role where he defines some of the public
policy
like
you know depending on how he thinks
about the world
millions of people could die because of
one decision he make yeah and that's a
lot of burden to walk with yeah no i
think that's right i don't think that he
has bad intentions
i think that he was
basically put was put or maybe put
himself in a position where
this kind of conflict of interest was
going to create this kind of this this
kind of a reaction
right the kind of humility that you're
calling for is almost impossible when
you have that dual dual role this that
shouldn't you shouldn't have to have as
as funder of science and also center of
scientific policy i agree with
everything you just said except the last
part the the humility is almost
impossible that
uh
humility is always difficult i think
i think there's a huge incentive to for
humility in that position
now look at history
great leaders that have humility
are popular as hell
so if you like being popular
if you like having impact legacy
these descendants of apes seem to care
about legacy especially as they get
older in these high positions like i i
think the incentive for humility is
pretty high well i mean the thing is is
like there's a lot that he has to be
proud of in his career i mean like the
human genome project
wouldn't have happened without him uh
and he is he is a great man and a great
scientist but so it is tragic to me that
his career has ended in this particular
way
he asked you a question about um
my podcast conversation with them
by way of advice or maybe criticism
there's a lot of people that wrote to me
kind words of support
and
a lot of people that wrote to me
respectful constructive criticism
how would you suggest to have
conversations with folks like that
and
maybe um i mean because there's i have
other conversations like this including
i was debating whether to talk to
anthony fauci he wanted to talk
and so
what kind of conversation do you have
and sorry to take us on a tangent but
almost from an interview
perspective of how to inspire humility
and inspire trust
in science or maybe give hope that we
know what the heck we're doing and we're
going to figure this out i mean i think
you're
i've been now interviewed by many people
um
i think uh
the style you have really works well lex
you have to you because you i don't
think you're going to be ever an attack
dog
trying to go after somebody and and
force them to to like
you know admit that they were wrong
about or whatever about i mean that's
that i also actually find that form of
journalism and podcasting really
off-putting it's hard to watch
also it's a whole lot of the tangent is
that actually effective i don't think so
do you want to ask
hitler
and i think about this a lot actually
interviewing hitler i've been studying a
lot about the the the rise and the fall
of the third reich
i think about interviewing stalin like i
put myself in that mindset like how do
you
have conversations with people to
understand who they are so that not so
you can sit there and yell at them yeah
but to understand who they are so that
you can inspire a very large number of
people to be the best version of
themselves and to avoid the mistakes of
the past i believe that everyone
that's involved in this debate has good
intentions they have they're coming at
it from their points of view uh they
they don't they have um
uh they have their weaknesses
and if you can paint a picture in your
questioning by sympathetic questioning
of those strengths and weaknesses and
their point of view you've done a
service um that's really all you i
personally like like to see in those
kinds of interviews um i don't think a
gotcha moment
uh is really the key thing there the the
key thing is understanding where they're
coming from understanding their thinking
understanding the constraints they faced
and how did they manage them that's
going to provide a much i mean for me
that's what i look for when i when i
listen to podcasts like yours
um is is an understanding of that of
that of that person
and the moment and how they dealt with
it
i mean i guess the hope is
to discover in a sympathetic way a flaw
in a person's thinking together
like
as opposed to discovering the positive
thing together you discover
the thing well i didn't really think
about that yeah i mean that's what
that's how science is right that's why
we found it i think find it so
attractive is this i i i like it when a
student shows me i'm thinking
incorrectly
right i think i'm really grateful to
that student because now i have an
opportunity to change my mind about it
and then start thinking even more
correctly i mean that's
and there are moments when
uh i mean like this is probably a good
time to say like what i think i got
wrong
during the pandemic right so like for
instance you said francis collins had a
moment when uh he learned that that
there was quite possible to get a
vaccine going yeah he must have learned
that quite early
and i didn't learn that early
i mean i i didn't know
in march of 2020
in my experience with vaccine
development it would have take i thought
it would take a decade or more to get a
vaccine
that was wrong right i didn't that that
and and i was so happy when i started to
see the preliminary numbers
in the in the pfizer trial
that strongly suggested it was going to
work
yeah and at the i was
i mean like very few times in my life
i'm so happy to be wrong
and it changes kind of
um i think i've heard you mention that
lockdown is still a bad idea
unless the vaccine comes out in like
tomorrow
uh there's still like
suffering and economic pain all kinds of
pain can still happen in even just a a
scale of weeks
um
versus months
yeah well let's talk about the vaccine
what are your thoughts on the safety and
efficacy of covered vaccines at the
individual and the societal level so for
the the vaccine safety data
it's it's actually challenging
to convey to the public how this is
normally done like normally you would do
this in the context of the trial you'd
have a law a long trial with large
numbers relatively large numbers of
people you'd follow them over a long
time and the trial will give you some
indication of the safety of the vaccine
and it did um i mean but
you the the the trial the way it was
constructed
when it was came out that it was
protective against covet it was no
longer ethical to have a placebo arm
and so that placebo arm is vaccinated
what large part of it
and so that meant that from the trial
you are not going to be able to get
data on the long-term safety profiles of
the vaccine
uh and also the other thing about trials
although there's tens of thousands of
people enrolled that's still not enough
to get when you when it when you deploy
a vaccine to the population scale you're
going to see things that weren't in the
trial
guaranteed
populations of people that weren't
represented well in the trial are going
to are going to be given the vaccine and
then that they're going to have things
that happen to them that you didn't
didn't anticipate
so
i wasn't surprised when people were a
little bit skeptical when the trial was
done about the safety profile just the
way the nature of the thing was going to
make it so that it was going to be hard
to get a complete picture from the
trials itself and the trials showed they
were pretty safe
and quite effective at preventing
both you from getting covid actually i
think the main endpoint of the trial
itself was a symptomatic covet
right so um uh so that was like that was
you know i mean it was really um
to me like is about as amazing
achievement as anything organizing a
trial of that scale and running it so
quickly
and the final results being so
surprisingly high so good right
and um so
the but the problem then was normally it
would take a long time the fda would
tell pfizer to go back and try it in
this subgroup they'd work more on dosing
they'd do all these kinds of things
that kind of didn't we really didn't
have time for in the middle of a
pandemic right so you have a you have
a basis for approval that it's less
full than normally you would have for a
population scale vaccine
but the results were good results looked
really good and actually i should say
for the most part that's been borne out
when we've given the vaccine at scale in
terms of protection against severe
disease
yeah all right so people who have got
the vaccine
um for a very long time after they've
had that for the full vaccination have
had great protection against going being
hospitalized and dying if they get
covered let's separate because this
seems to be
um
there's critics of both categories but
different kids
and
kids and
old not older people like uh
let's say five years old and above or
something like they're 13 years old and
above so
for those it seems like the reduction
of uh the rate of fatalities and and
serious illness seems to be something
like 10x
i mean for older people it is a godsend
this vaccine it it transforms the the
problem of focus protection from
something that's quite challenging
possible i believe but quite challenging
to something that's much much more
manageable because the vaccine in and of
itself when deployed in older
populations is a form of focus
protection
yes well by the way we'll talk about the
focus protection in one segment because
it's such a brilliant idea for this
pandemic of future pandemics i thought
the sociological psychological
discussion about the letter from francis
collins is um
because it was so recent it was been so
troubling to me so i'm glad we talked
about that first
but so the there seems to be
the vaccines work to reduce deaths
and that has especially the most
transformative effects for the older so
can i let you give i've told you one
thing that i got wrong in the panic let
me tell you the second thing i got wrong
for sure in the pandemic
in january of la of this year
2021 i thought that the vaccines would
stop infection
yes right it would would make it so that
you were much less likely to be infected
at all
because the the antibodies that were
produced by the vaccines looked like
they were neutralizing antibodies that
would would essentially block you from
being infected at all
um
that turned out to be wrong
right so i think it became clear
as data came out from israel which
vaccinated very early that they were
seeing surges of infection even in a
very highly vaccinated population
that
that the vaccine does not stop infection
so you're a used car salesman and you're
selling the vaccine
and the features you thought of vaccine
would have i mean i have a similar kind
of sense when the vaccine came out
vaccine would
reduce
if you somehow were able to get it you
would reduce rate of death and all those
kinds of things but it would also reduce
the chance of you
getting it and if you do get it the
chance that you transmitting it to
somebody else
and it turns out that those latter two
things are not as uh definitive or in
fact they're i mean i don't know to
which agree they're not i mean i think
it's it's a little complicated because i
think the first two or three months
after you're fully vaccinated after the
second dose you have
60 70 percent efficacy peak against
infection yeah so uh that which is
pretty good i mean right but by
six seven eight months that drops to 20
percent some places some studies like
there's a study out of sweden suggested
it might even drop to zero but and then
you're also infectious for some period
of time if you do get it even though
you're vaccinated correct although there
seems to be
lucy data that the period of time your
infectious is short it's shorter but the
the infectivity per day is about as high
so you still it's the point is that that
the vaccine might reduce some risk of
infecting others but it's not a
categorical difference
so uh a unvaccine it's not safe to be in
the presence of just vaccinated people
you can still get infected
right so i mean there's a million things
i want to ask here but
is there in some sense because the
vaccine
um
really helps on the worst
part of this pandemic which is killing
people yes
uh doesn't that mean
uh where does the vaccine hesitancy come
from
in terms of it seems like obviously a
vaccine is a powerful solution to let us
open this thing up yeah so i wrote a
wall street journal op-ed with sinatra
gupta in december of last year yes a
very night with a very naive title which
says we can end the lockdowns in a month
and the idea is very simple
vaccinate
all
vulnerable people
and then
open up open up right uh and the idea
was that uh the the lockdown harms this
is related this is directly related to
the great barrington declaration the
great antarctic clergy said the lockdown
harms are devastating
to the population at large
there's this
considerable segment of people that are
vulnerable
protect them well with the vaccine we
have a perfect tool to protect the
vulnerable which is i still believe i
mean is true right you vaccinate the
vulnerable the older population and as
you said there's a tenfold decrease in
the mortality risk
um from getting infected
which is i mean amazing so that was the
strategy we got we outlined what
happened is that the vaccine debate got
transformed so first there's so you're
asking about vaccine hesitance i think
there's there's first there's like
there's there's the inherent
limitations of how to measure vaccine
safety right so we talked about a little
bit about the trial but also after the
trial there's a there's a there's a
mechanism and this is the work i've been
involved with before covet on
on tracking and and identifying and
checking whether the vaccines actually
are safe and the central challenge is
one of causality
so you no longer have the randomized
trial
but but you want to know is the vaccine
when is deployed at scale
causing
adverse events
well you can't just look at people who
are vaccinated and see what adverse
events happen
because you don't know what would have
happened if the person had not been
vaccinated
so you have to have some control group
now what happened is there's several
systems to do to check this in that the
cdc uses one one very very very commonly
known one now is called vares the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
there anyone who has an adverse event
that either either a regular person or a
doctor can just go report look i have
the vaccine and two days later i had a
headache or whatever it is
the person died
a day after the vaccine right um now you
vaccinate that the vaccine was rolled
out to older people first
and older people die sometimes with or
without the vaccine so
sometimes you'll see someone's
vaccinated and a few days later they die
did the vaccine cause it or something
else cause it's really difficult to tell
in order to tell you need a control
group
for that um
there are other systems the fda and cdc
have
uh like there's one called vsd vaccine
safety data link there's another system
called best
uh
i forget the app with the acronym is to
essentially to track uh cohorts of
people
vaccinated versus unvaccinated was as
careful of matching as you can do it's
not randomized but and then c
if you have
safety signals that pop up in the
vaccinated relative to the control group
unvaccinated
um and so that's for instance how the
the the myocarditis risk was picked up
in young young especially young men
it's also how the
higher risk of blood clots in middle age
and older women in with the jnj vaccine
is picked
up there what you have is are situations
where the baseline risk of these
outcomes are so low that if you see them
in the con in the vaccinated arm at all
then it's not hard to understand that
the vaccine did this right
young men should not be having
myocarditis
middle-aged women should not be having
huge blood clots in the brain right um
so when you see that you can say it's
linked now the rates are low so young
men maybe one in five thousand one in
ten thousand of the vaccine of my
vaccine-related myocarditis pericarditis
um young women of middle-aged women i
don't know i don't i'm not sure what the
right number might be but like i'd say
it's like in the you know one in
hundreds of thousands something like
that
so these are rare outcomes but they're
they're they are vaccinating linked
outcomes
how do you deal with that as a messaging
thing i think you just tell people you
tell people here are the risks you
transparently tell them and just you're
not you're not they're so they're not
getting into something that they don't
know
yeah and um don't treat people like
their children and need to be told lies
because they won't understand the full
complexity of the truth uh people i
think are pretty good at um or actually
you know
people with time are good at
understanding data but better than
anything they're uh
they're better at they're extremely good
at detecting arrogance and [ __ ] and
yeah give them either one of those i
mean i'll give you one that's where i
think it's greatly undermined vaccine
has
greatly undermined the demand for the
vaccine is this weird denial that if you
recover from kovid you have extremely
good
immunity both against infection and
actually exchange
and that denial
leads to people distrusting the message
given by like the cdc director for
instance favored the vaccine
right why would you deny a thing that's
such an obvious fact it's like you can
look at the data and it just i mean it
just just pops out at you that people
that are covered recovered
are not getting infected again at very
high rates
much lower rates after these kinds of
conversations um
i'm sure after this com very
conversation i often get uh a number of
messages from joe joe rogan and from sam
harris who to me are people i admire i
think are really intelligent thoughtful
human beings they also have a platform
and i i i believe at least in my mind
about this coveted
set of topics they represent
a group of people
each group has
smart
thoughtful
well-intentioned human beings and i
don't know who is right
but i i do know that they're kind of
tribal a little bit
uh those groups and so
the question i want to ask is like what
do you think about these
uh two
groups and this kind of tension over the
vaccine
that sometimes it just keeps finding
different topics
on which to focus on like whether kids
should get vaccinated or not whether
there should be vaccine mandates or not
which seem to be often very kind of
specific policy kinds of questions right
it's the bigger picture i think it's a
symptom of the distrust that people have
in public health
i think this kind of schism over the the
vaccine does not happen in places where
the public health authorities have been
much more trustworthy
right so you don't see this vaccine
hasn't seen sweden for instance
um
what's happened in the united states is
the vaccine has become
first because of politics but then also
because of the scientific arrogance this
sort of touchstone issue and people line
up on you on both sides of it and the
different language you're hearing
is structured around that so before the
election for instance i did uh
uh i was a i did a testimony in the
house on on measurement of vaccine
safety
and i i was i was invited by the
republicans there were i think uh four
other experts invited by the democrats
or three other experts invited by
democrats
each of whom had a lot of experience in
measuring vaccine safety i was really
surprised to hear them each
doubt whether the fda would do a
reasonable job in assessing vaccine
safety
including by people who have long
records of working with the fda
i mean these are
professionals
great scientists whose main you know
sort of goal in life is to make sure
that safe vaccine that that unsafe
vaccines don't get released into the
world and if they argue they get pulled
and they're casting down on the vaccine
the ability to track vaccine safety
before the election
and then after the election
the the rhetoric switched on a dime
right all of a sudden it's republicans
that are cast as if they're vaccine
hesitant
that kind of political shift
the public notices
if if all it takes is an election to
change how people talk about the safety
of the vaccine well we're not talking
science anymore many people think right
i think that creates created its
hesitancy
the other thing i think the um
the
the hesitancy
some politicians viewed it as a
political
as sort of like a political opportunity
to sort of demonize people who were
hesitant
and that itself fueled hesitancy right
like the if you're if you're telling me
i'm a rube that just doesn't want the
vaccine because i want everyone to die
well i'm gonna i'm gonna react really
negatively
and if you're talking down to me
about
my legitimate
you know sort of
concerns about whether this vaccine's
safe to i mean i've like heard from
women who are thinking about getting
pregnant should i take the vaccine i
don't know i mean there are all kinds of
questions
legitimate questions that i think
should have good data to answer that we
don't necessarily have good data to
answer so what do you do in the face of
that
well
one reaction is to pretend like we we
know for a fact that it's safe
when we don't have the data to know for
fact in that particular group with that
particular set of clinical circumstances
you know
and that i think breeds hesitancy people
can detect that [ __ ] um whereas if
you just tell people you know i don't
know
yeah you deal with humility yeah you're
gonna you're you'll end up with a better
result
let me ask you about i've recently had a
conversation with the pfizer ceo
this is
part therapy session part advice because
i again i really want
us to get through this together and it
feels like the division is a thing that
uh prevents us from getting through this
together
and uh once again just like with francis
collins a lot of people
wrote to me
words of support
and a lot of people wrote to me words of
criticism
i'm trying to understand
the nature of the criticism
so some of the criticism had to do with
against the vaccine and those kinds of
things that i have a better
understanding of
but
some kind of deep distrust
of pfizer
so
um
actually looking at uh big pharma
broadly
i'm trying to
understand
am i so naive
that i just don't see it
because yes there's corrupt people and
they they're greedy they're flawed in
all walks of life
but uh companies
do
quite an incredible job of taking a good
idea at the scale and making some money
with that idea but they are the ones
that achieve scale on a good idea
i don't know
it's not obvious to me i don't see
where the manipulation is so the fear
that people have and
i talked to joe about this quite a bit i
i think this is a legitimate fear and
and a fury should often have that money
has influenced disproportional influence
especially in politics so the fear is
that
the policy
of uh the vaccine was connected to the
fact that
lots of money could be made
by manufacturing the vaccine
and i understand that
and i'm it's actually quite a heck of a
difficult task to alleviate that concern
like you really have to be a great man
or woman or a leader to convince people
that you're not full of [ __ ] that you're
not just playing a game on them
i don't know it's a it's a difficult
task but at the same time i i really
don't like the natural
distrust every billionaire distrust
everybody who's trying to make money
because it feels like under a
capitalistic system at least
the the way to do a lot of good like to
do good at scale in the world
is by
being at least in part motivated by the
profit i mean i share your ambivalence
right so on the one hand you have a a
fantastic achievement the the the
manufacture the discovery of the vaccine
and then the manufacturing at scale
so that
you know billions of people can take the
vaccine in a relatively short time that
is a remarkable achievement that could
not have happened without companies like
pfizer
um on the other hand the there is this
sort of corrupting influence of that
money
uh uh just to give you one example uh
there's a there's an enormous
controversy over whether uh relatively
inexpensive repurposed drugs can be used
to treat the the the disease
um
none of no company like pfizer has any
interest whatsoever in evaluating it
even merck i think support was merck
that
had the patent on ivormectin
uh now expired has no interest at all in
checking to see if it works
not only do they not have interest
they have
a way of talking about people who might
have a little bit of interest
that's again um fringe
uh
full of arrogance yeah
and that that is what troubles me
is there not a it's back to the play of
science it's not they're not a bit of
curiosity one okay one the natural
curiosity of a human being that should
always be there and an open mind is and
second in the case of ivermectin and
other things like that you have to
acknowledge that there's a very large
number of people
who care about this topic and this is a
way to inspire them to also play in the
space of science to inspire them with
science you can't just like dismiss
everybody
that uh you can't just dismiss people
period yeah well i mean i think here
here take ivermectin right there's
actually a study
funded by the nih by tony fauci's nia id
and the nih
um called active six
that's
a randomized trial of ivermectin
it's due to be completed in march 2023
so normally when you have uh private
actors like these big
drug companies that have no interest in
conducting some kind of scientific
experiment that would have some public
benefit
it's the job of the of the the
government and in this case the nih to
fund that kind of work the nih has been
incredibly slow
in its evaluations of these repurposed
drugs
and it's been left to lots of other
private private private activities
of uneven quality
and hence that's why you have these
these big fights
because the data are not solid you're
gonna have these big fights yeah but
also okay forget the the process of
science here the studies not enough
effort being put into the studies just
the way it's being communicated yeah no
like horse pace i mean come on the fda
put a tweet out telling people who are
like
they're taking iron mechanism because
they've heard good things about it and
they're sick and they're desperate and
just call it horse pace was just that
was that was terrible that was deeply
responsible my hope um is grounded in
the fact that young people see the the
[ __ ] of this young phd students
graduate students young students in
college they see
the the
less than stellar way that our
scientific leaders and our political
leaders are behaving and then the new
generation will not repeat the mistakes
of the past that is my hope because uh
that that's the cool thing i see about
young people is they they
they're good at detecting [ __ ] and
they they don't want to be part of that
um that's my hope um in the space of
science
let me return to this idea of the great
barrington declaration return to the
beginning
so um what are the basics can you
describe what the great barrington
declaration is what are some of the
ideas in it you mentioned focused
protection
uh what are your concerns about
lockdowns just paint the picture of this
early proposal sure so uh the great
painting declaration first why is it
called great barrington declaration it
sounds it's such a great name
you
i mean it just it's such an epic name
but the the reason why it's called that
is way less than epic it's it was it was
because it the the conference um which
is organized by martin kuldorf who's a
was a professor at harvard university uh
by a statistician he actually
designed
the the safety system the statistical
system that the
fda uses
for
tracking vaccine safety
he
and i had met previously just the summer
before that summer
and he invited me to come to this small
conference where he was inviting me and
sinatra gupta who was a professor of
theoretical epidemiology at harvard
at oxford university
and i mean i jumped at the chance
uh because i knew that martin and
sinatra were both smarter than me and uh
it would be fun to like talk about what
uh what the right strategy would be
on the drive in i didn't know what the
name of the town was and i asked as they
said was great barrington i had in the
back of my head
um martin and i arrived a little early
and we were writing an op-ed about some
of the ideas i hope we get to talk about
very soon um about focus protection and
the right strategy and uh when sinetra
arrived we realized we actually come
basically to the same place about the
right
way to deal with the epidemic
um and i i thought well why don't we put
issue why don't we write something like
the port hearing statement that was what
i had that in the back of my head yes
and i'm like well what's the name of
this town again it was great barrington
yeah so it's not barrington
it's great bear it's which is fantastic
right
it's so over the top that it's perfect
it's it's
literally like the big bang
there's something about these
over-the-top fun titles that just really
deliver them
so that's why that's my my main
contribution was the word is the title
the name great barrington decor um but
yeah so it was it was kind of uh so the
and the the idea is actually
while the title is great um and i think
that it was written in a very stylish
way
um it's you know like it's a go it's
less than a page you can go look online
and read it it's written written for
not for scientists but for the general
public so people can understand the
ideas really simply
but it is not actually a radical set of
ideas it actually represents the old
pandemic plans
that we've used for century
dealing with other similar pandemics
um and and there's it's twofold uh first
let me talk about the science it rests
on and then i'll talk about the plan
the science actually some of what we
already talked about uh there's this
massive age gradient in the risk of
coven infection older people face much
higher risk than younger people
the second bit of science is all that's
not controversial right that even if you
think the ifr is 0.7 or or or 0.2 no
matter what everyone thinks everyone
agrees on this age gradient
the second bit of science is also not
controversial
the lockdown focused policies that we
followed
have absolutely devastating consequences
on the health of the population
let me just give you some examples uh
and this is this was known in october of
2020 we wrote it right so um the un was
sounding alarms that there would be
tens of millions of people who would
starve as a consequence of the economic
dislocation caused by the lockdowns
and that's come to pass
hundreds of thousands of children in
places like south asia dead from
starvation
as a consequence of lockdowns
um
the the the the uh uh
priorities like
the treatment of patients with
tuberculosis
in poor countries stopped
because of lockdowns
uh
childhood vaccinations of
measles rubella
dpt diphtheria so on pertussis tetanus
all those standard vaccination campaigns
stopped
tens of millions of children skipping
these doses
for diseases that are actually deadly
for them
is there just a on a small tangent
is it well understood to you what are
the mechanisms that stop all those
things because of lockdowns is it some
aspect of supply chain is it just
literally because
hospital doors are closed
is it because there's a disincentive to
go outside by people even when they
deeply need help it's all of the above
uh but a lot of those efforts especially
especially those like vaccination
efforts are funded and run by what
western efforts like gavi is a
i think it's a gates funded thing
actually that produce provides vaccines
for you know millions of kids worldwide
and those efforts were scaled back
malaria prevention efforts so in the
developing world it was a devastating
effect these lockdowns um there was also
direct effects like in india the
uh the lockdowns when they first
instituted there was an order that 10
million migrant workers
who live in big cities and they live
hand-to-mouth they buy you know coconuts
they sell the coconuts with the money
they buy food for themselves and
coconuts for the next day to sell um
walk back to their villages or get or
get go back to their villages then
overnight so 10 million people walking
back to their villages or taking a train
back a thousand died on route
overcrowded trains dying essentially on
the side of the road i mean it was it
was absolutely inhumane policy
uh and uh the lockdowns there
what what it's it's actually it's kind
of like what's happened to the west as
well but it was so severe uh there was a
zero prevalence study done in mumbai by
a friend of mine at the university of
chicago what he found was that in the
slums of mumbai
there were 70 surah prevalence in july
or august of seven of sept of 2020
whereas in the rest of mumbai is 20
yeah right so it was incredibly unequal
the the lockdowns protected the the
relatively well off and spread the
disease
among the poor
um so uh that's in the developing world
in the developed world the health
effects of lockdowns were
also quite bad
right so we talked already about
isolation and depression there was a
study done in july of 2020
that found that one in four young adults
seriously considered suicide
now suicide rates haven't like spiked up
so much but the depths of despair that
would lead somebody to seriously
consider suicide itself should be should
be a source of great concern for in
public health
yeah this is one of the troubling things
about measuring well-being is
we're okay at measuring death and
suicide
we're not so good at measuring suffering
it's like people talk about
um maybe even
harder more in the under stalin or the
concentration camps with hitler we talk
about deaths
but we don't talk about
the suffering over periods of years
by people living in fear by people
starving
psychological trauma that lasts a
lifetime all of those things
i mean and just to get back to that that
point we close schools especially in
blue states we close schools
now richer parents could send their kids
to private schools many of which stayed
open even in the blue states they could
get pods they could get tutors but
that's not true for for poorer and
middle class parents
and as a result what we did is we took
away life opportunities for kids we we
tried to teach
five-year-olds to read via zoom in
kindergarten
right uh
and uh the consequence actually you
think okay we can just make it up but
it's really difficult to make that up
there's a literature in health economics
that shows that even uh
you know
relatively small disruptions in
schooling can have lifelong consequences
negative consequences for kids
right so they end up growing up poorer
they they lead shorter lives and less
healthy lives
as a consequence that's and that's what
the literature now shows is likely to
happen with the interruptions of
schooling that we had in the united
states many european countries actually
managed to avoid this there were in the
early days the epidemic great
indications that children first were not
very severe severely at risk from covet
itself
nor are they super spreaders
schools were not the source of community
spread communities spread spread
the disease to schools not the other way
around
um and if we can talk about the
scientific basis of that if you'd like
but that was pretty well known even in
october
um it that we we closed hospitals in
order to keep them
like available to covet patients but as
a result
women skipped breast cancer screening
as a result they have are showing up
with
late stage breast cancer that should
have been picked up last year
men and women skipped colon cancer
screening again with later stage disease
that should have been picked up last
year with earlier stage for patients
with diabetes
it's very important to have regular
screening for blood sugar levels
and and sort of counseling for lifestyle
improvement and we skipped that
people stayed home with heart attacks
and died at home with heart attacks
so you had this like sort of wide range
of medical
and psychological harms
that were being utterly ignored
as a result of the lockdowns
plus there's the economic pain
so like you said the
whatever is a good term for the
non-laptop class
people would lose their jobs yes there
might be in the in the western world
support for them
financially but the the big loss there
that is perhaps correlated with the
depression and suicide is uh
loss of meaning loss of hope for the
future a loss of kind of a sense of
stability all the pride you have and
being able to um
make
money that allows you to pave your own
way in the world
and yes just having less money than
you're used to so your family your kids
are suffering all those kinds of things
and there's a there's again an economics
literature on this on deaths of despair
it was called 2009 there was the the
great recession it led to an enormous
uptick in overdose from drugs
uh suicidality depression
as a result of the job losses that
happened during the great recession
well that's happening again like an
enormous increase
in drug overdoses
that's not uh that's not a an accident
that's a lockdown harm right same same
thing with uh with the job losses the
job losses by the way are like it's so
interesting because the um the states
that stayed open have had
much much lower unemployment than the
states that stayed closed
uh the labor force participation rates
declined by three percent it's women
that separated because
they stayed home with their kids um
we've reversed a generation of women uh
when
proving women's participation in the
labor force
do you think
it has to do with institutions that
we mentioned that there is so much
priority given or so much power given to
maybe nih
versus um
other civilian leaders or do people just
not care about the economic pain the
leaders i mean uh because to me it was
obvious
i mean probably it's just studying
history
whenever i listen to people on twitter
on mainstream news or just anything
i realize that's the very kind of top
the the people that have a voice
represent a tiny selection of people and
so whenever there's hard times i always
kind of think about the the quiet
the voiceless
the quiet suffering of the tens of
millions of the hundreds of millions
um
do the political leaders not just give a
damn i mean i think it was actually a
very odd ethical thing at the beginning
of the pandemic where if you brought up
economic harms at all
you were seen as callous
right so i i i had a reporter calling me
up almost the very beginning of the
epidemic asking me about about the about
uh
uh
like a very particular phenomenon so
like uh he he was anticipating a rise in
child abuse because children were gonna
be staying at home child abuse is
generally picked up at school
and that actually happened like so like
the the child reported child abuse
dropped but actual child abuse increased
um
because normally you pick up the child
abuse at school and that you apparently
you have the intervention right so yeah
so i was talking about like well there's
gonna be some economic harms and they're
going to have health consequences but
the economic harms matter but the but
he's he he counseled me and i think he
was he had his bet my best interest at
heart like if if we were to put that in
the story i would be i'd essentially be
canceled because the what the what the
uh the the narrative that that arose in
march of 2020 is if you if you care
about money at all
you're evil and crass if you you must
only care about lives
the problem with that narrative is that
that money which we're talking about is
is actually lives of poor people
right when you throw 100 million people
around the world into into poverty
you're going to see enormous harm to
their health enormous increases in their
in their mortality it's not immoral to
think about that and and worry about
that
in the context of this pandemic response
our mind focused so much on kovid that
it forgot that there are so many other
public health priorities as well that
need our attention desperately and this
is the thing i
sensed about san francisco when i
visited i was thinking of moving there
for startup
this is the thing i'm really afraid of
especially if i have any
effect on the world through a startup is
losing touch in this kind of way
that uh you mentioned the laptop class
um
living in this world where you're only
concerned about this particular
of class of people and also
uh you know perhaps in early on in the
pandemic amongst the laptop class there
was a legitimate concern for health like
you're not sure
how deadly this virus is you don't
you're not sure who to listen to so
there's a real concern
and then at a certain point when the
data starts coming in you start becoming
more and more detached from the data you
don't start carrying less and less and
you start just
swimming in the space of narratives like
existing the space of narratives and you
have this narrative
in san francisco in the laptop class
that you just are very uh proud that you
know the truth you're the sole
possessors of the truth you congratulate
yourself on it and you don't care what
actually
gigantic detrimental effect it has on
society because
you're mostly
fine
that i'm so terrified of that
well i think the answer to that is just
to
you
remember
yeah yeah
i don't think um you know remember where
you came from remember who who who
you're doing is for at the back of your
head should always be what's what's the
purpose like why am i here what's the
purpose of this and if i'm if if the
purpose is simply
self-aggrandizement then you should
rethink because it'll just end up being
a hall of life
all of us will be forgotten in the end
focus protection
the idea the policy what is focus
protection right so those i was saying
that there's two scientific bases right
so one is this the steep age gradient
the second is the existence of locked
arms again i think there's not very
little disagreement in the scientific
community of both of those facts
if you put those facts together
the obvious policy is to protect the
people who are at the most severe risk
from the disease itself
and that's the idea of focus protection
that's the general principle of it
the actual implementation of it depends
on the living circumstances of the
people that are at risk
the resources are available in the
community uh the the uh the technology
is available to do this
and so it's almost always going to be in
fact it'll always be a local thing
because it'll depend on the the the all
of those those things which are all
local in nature
right so one very very obvious thing in
a country like ours where so many older
people live in institutionalized
settings in nursing home settings
and that's where older really vulnerable
chronically ill patients often live
it is and you know this disease affects
that group most like most most commonly
it is absolutely vital to protect that
group
um we should have known that in february
2020 from just from the chinese data
and
we should have thought about that group
as the as this as the key constraint
in our policy making
um instead we thought about in february
march 2020 as hospital beds as the key
constraint
hospital beds and ventilator shortages
and that we so we we ran around trying
to like address that
constraint you know like a linear
programming problem you figure out what
the which constraints binding and you
address that one thing and then you go
to the next one right um if that's it's
that one constraint we said okay the
constraint is hospital beds
that led to the decision in many of the
northeast states to send
covet infected patients who were on on
the verge of like it looked like they
were about to recover back to nursing
homes
who then spread the disease all through
there because they wanted to preserve
the hospital beds
well for somebody who loves the miracle
optimization i love the way you frame
this
but those are kind of connected right if
you actually focus on protecting the
vulnerable you will also
have the effect of
not
hitting the ceiling of the available
that is that's the irony if we protected
the vulnerable the vulnerable the most
likely to be hospitalized and so by
protecting the hospital about protecting
the vulnerable we would also have
addressed the shortage of hospital
that's more effectively so that little
shift in priority would have had a big
impact
okay but specifically the idea is to
and we could talk about different ideas
of how to actually do this but uh you
know you
basically do a lockdown or something
like that on a very small set i mean you
may have to do that if it's community
spread is very high but generally i
think
it would depend on again the living
circumstances and the uh so so for
instance um
if you are in a if you have a here's a
very simple idea that doesn't require a
lockdown
forced on them i i don't actually
generally are not in favor of that kind
of force lockdown because you just won't
get cooperation
um but what you could do is provide
resources to
that group of people so like ima imagine
you live next door to somebody uh an
older couple
um and it's there's high community
spread
well they have to go grocery shopping
um we did like some of these some
communities did these like senior only
grocery hour right but but they have to
still have to go out and they might get
exposed in when they're shopping amongst
other seniors yeah
well why not organized home delivery of
groceries to them we did that for the
laptop class
right uh or or you can even just there's
a volunteer effort you know the older
people living next door just call them
up and say can i help you get uh go out
and go shopping for it and so you would
have potentially
federal support of that kind of thing so
these kinds of efforts and identify
where the vulnerable people live uh it's
really challenging in multi-generational
homes in l.a county for instance there's
a lot of
older people living together with
younger people in relatively crowded
they're they're it's really quite a
challenge but there again you can use
resources so if grandma uh
is worried that grandson has come home
but is potentially been exposed grandson
calls grandma says i've been i might
have been at a party where i might do
that where covid was grandma calls
public health public health and then
says okay you can have this hotel room
for a couple of days
until you check to turn negatives in
case it wasn't clear
the idea of focus protection
is the people that are
vulnerable protect them
and everybody else goes on with their
lives open up the economy just do as it
was before and there was still fear
abroad so there still would be some
restrictions people would pose on
themselves they probably would go to
parties less the grandsons probably
wouldn't go so many parties right um uh
that there would be less
less participation in big gatherings uh
you may even save like big gatherings in
order to restrict community spread again
i'm not against any of that
but you shouldn't be closing businesses
you shouldn't be closing churches and
synagogues you shouldn't be closing you
shouldn't be forcing people to not go to
to school you should
you should not be shuttering businesses
you should just let
just allow society to go on some disease
will spread but as we've seen the
lockdown didn't stop the disease from
spreading anyways
right so what do you make of the
criticism that this idea like
all good ideas
cannot actually be implemented in a
heterogeneous society where there's a
lot of people intermixing
and
once you open it up people like the the
younger people will just forget that
this is even existing and they'll stop
caring about the older people and mess
up the whole thing and the government
will not want to fund
any kind of the great efforts you're
talking about about food delivery and
then the food delivery services be like
why the heck am i helping out on this
anyway because like it's not making me
much money and so therefore like all
good ideas it will collapse
that might be true i mean i think it's
always a risk with policy thing but i
think like think back to the moment
we actually felt like we were in this
together to some extent yes
right i think i think that that um that
empathy that we had that was used to
like
tell people to stay in and like happily
not don't rule in happily but like stay
in
um to to like wear a mask or to to do
all these things that we thought would
help other people
could have been redirected to actually
helping the people who most needed to be
especially
i do remember
[Music]
march uh so this is even way before
barrington all that kind of stuff
march april may
there was a feeling like if if we all
just work together
yeah we'll solve this right and that
maybe started to when did that start
breaking down i mean the
unfortunately the election is mixed into
this yeah that it became politicized but
i think it lasted quite a long time i
think into the summer i think there was
some some of that sense uh i don't know
they're obviously varied among different
people but um
but i think that it's true it would have
been challenging it's also true that
it's heterogeneous exactly the way you
said um but what that means is you need
a local response
a response so like like my vision of a
public health officer is someone that
understands their community
not not necessarily the nation at large
but their community and then works
within their community to figure out how
to deploy the resources that have
available
um to do the kind of protection policies
we're talking about that's that's what
should have happened instead they spent
a huge amount of efforts closing making
sure businesses stayed closed
businesses that
i mean there were you know like hardware
stores that closed
what good did closing a hardware store
do
for the spreader club if it had an
effect on spread covert spread i mean
it's going to be checking to make sure
that plexiglas was put up everywhere
which now in retrospect turns out to
have probably made the disease worse
um
you know masking enforcement
so shaming around mask i mean a huge
amount of effort on things that were
only tangentially related to focus
protection what if we turned our energy
that enormous energy put into that
instead into focused protection of the
vulnerable that's essentially the
conversation i was calling for
and it wasn't i mean i didn't think of
it as we had every single idea i mean we
gave some concrete proposals
and we got but the criticism we got was
that those those concrete proposals
weren't enough
and the answer to that i have is that's
true they weren't enough i wasn't
thinking of them as enough i was
thinking that they would i wanted to
involve an enormous number of people in
local public health to help think about
how to do focus protection in their
communities
the question that's interesting here is
about the future too
uh so uh covet has very specific
characteristics like you mentioned about
the curve of the the the death rate
based on the like it's it's uh it seems
like with covid it's a little bit easier
to actually identify a group of people
that you need to protect
so other viruses may not be this way so
might lock down be a good idea like hard
core lockdown for future virus
that's 10 times deadlier but spreads at
the same rate as covid or maybe another
way to ask that is imagine a virus
that's 10 times deadlier what's the
right response
i mean i think it's always going to be
focus protection but the group that
needs the focus protection may change
depending on the biology of the virus
right so the polio
epidemic in the 40s and 50s in the u.s
the the great the people at most risk
were children
we didn't know really at the beginning
there was this vehicle oral spread
and so we did all kinds of crazy things
um
including like spreading spraying ddt in
communities
which was somehow supposed to get rid of
polio um but the focus was on whenever
there was an outbreak they would close a
school down
and that was the right thing to do
because that group that needed
protection
where it was
children and those the disease was
spread we thought in schools
i don't think there's a single formula
that works but there's a single
principle that works right no matter i
can't it's hard to imagine a disease
that's uniformly deadly across every
group and every single person
there's always going to be some group
that's differentially
harmed
uh there's always going to be some group
that's differentially protected and that
that may change over time right so like
the in the uh
in this disease in this epidemic
as people got infected and recovered we
now had a class of people that were
pretty well protected against the
disease
they should be they would like instead
of ostracizing them because they don't
want a vaccine we should we should be
allowing them to work i mean we're
having
staffing shortages in hospitals now
because we forgot that principle
is uh
quite a bit of this a technology problem
so being able to so some of it how much
of it is this uh sociological problem
uh how much of it is a technology
problem
like where do you uh put the blame
sort of on why this didn't go so great
and how it can go great in the beginning
i mean think about lockdowns like if we
didn't have zoom we wouldn't have
lockdowns right there's
there's a reason in 2009 we didn't lock
down i mean we didn't have the
technology to replace work with this
remote
um with this remote technology
so we had good lockdown technology yeah
and zoom we didn't have
good focus protection technology yeah i
mean focus protection is always going to
be complicated especially for something
like this that's spread so easily it's
going to be complicated and i'm i'm very
i'm the last person to say would have
been perfect there's there would have
been people that would have gotten sick
but they got sick anyways the hope was
that if we suppress community spread low
enough
we can protect the vulnerable
that was the hope by lockdown
the reality was that
only a certain class of people were able
to benefit from a lockdown the rest of
society we call them essential workers
had to keep working and they got sick
yeah
and the disease kept spreading it didn't
actually have a substantial effect on
community spread in the in in non
laptop class populations
and also we should probably expand the
class of people who call vulnerable to
those who would suffer who have the
capacity to suffer
given the policies they're you're
weighing
it's very
disingenuous to call the vulnerable just
the people
obviously we had the very specific
meaning but broadly speaking vulnerable
should uh include anybody who can suffer
based on the policies you take in
response to a virus there's something
this is that principle you just said as
i completely agree with is is uh
something i think has been lost
uh
and unfortunately lost right so
the policies themselves
if they have harm those are real
yeah and we shouldn't pretend like
they're not
and and and essentially demonize the
people that that that suffer them
or pretend i mean like us a lot of times
like the depression that we've been
talking about that's
thought of as like not as not so
important but it is important uh and uh
uh especially the the harm to the people
in poor countries it's like been out of
sight item out of mind in much of the
rich parts of the world
once again i've hoped that we
seeing this learning the lessons of
history with the communication tools who
have now will learn this it's like going
to another country and bombing targeted
terrorist locations
and there's going to be some civilians
who die
pretending that that
the child who watches their dad die is
not going to grow up first of all
traumatized but second of all
potentially bring more hate to the world
than uh the hate that you were allegedly
fighting in the first place that's
another sort of
um considering only one kind of harm and
not the full range of harms that are
being caused by your policies you know
like the good return to focus protection
we we still should be following the
policy now for covet and we're not
right so the vaccines
are there's a great shortage in vaccines
you wouldn't know it in the united
states and in rich parts of the world
but in there's a great shortage of
vaccines we're not going to be able to
vaccinate the um most of the like the
entire set of elderly at least and or
larger groups until late 2022.
huge numbers of older people around the
world in poor countries that have not
had not covered recovered yet so they're
still quite vulnerable have not had the
vaccine
and yet we're talking about vaccinating
five-year-olds
yeah
who benefit
if at all from the vaccines of just a
very little bit because they face such a
low risk of harm from covid
well something that's a little bit
near and dear to our specific the two of
our hearts uh so you're at stanford
so stanford recently
announced that they're going back to
virtual
at least for some period of time in
response to the esc maybe you can
clarify but i think it's in response to
the escalated um
holiday phrase it's related to omicron
and uh a few other universities are kind
of like
uh considering back and forth in my
perspective
as somebody who loves in-person lectures
who
um
sees the value of that
to students to young minds
also looking at the data
seems
the
[Music]
risk aversion
in university policies around this given
how healthy the student population is
seems not well calibrated let's put it
this way also pathological pathological
is one way to put it given that i
believe depending on the university but
i think
many universities require that the
student body is vaccinated
at this point
so
i think it's a big mistake by stanford
to do this
and um
i i'd like to say that because i just
hope mit doesn't
but what are your thoughts about
everything things
i completely agree with you i think um
we have
failed in our mission
to educate our students
by these this decision uh and i think i
frankly just more broadly i think we
failed generally over the course of the
last year and a half in living up to our
educational mission
the in-person
teaching is vital
for and now i can understand you have
you have older faculty
the principle of focus protection says
provide some alternative teaching
arrangements for them
that makes sense to me
from the kids point of view
they're more harmed by not getting the
education we promised them
than by than by covid
so applying this principle of this focus
protection
let young professors teach in person
this is before the vaccine after the
vaccine let everyone teach in person
yeah this this the part i don't
understand the discussion we're even
having
um
okay let's leave focus protection aside
here because that's a brilliant policy
for perhaps for the future when there's
no vaccine
now with the vaccine i'm i'm
misunderstanding something here because
we're now in a space
that's
psychological not it's no longer about
biology because
uh with the booster shots which i
believe mit is now requiring before
january
with the booster shots the data shows no
matter how old you are the risks are
very low
for um
ending up in a hospital
relative to all the other risks you face
when you're older
i don't i don't understand can you
explain the policy around
closing
a university but also just a
policy about
just being so
uh scared still
in the university setting i think the
universities the great university has
done great harm
by modeling this kind of behavior yes
that to me decided to keep interrupting
but to me the university should be the
beacon of great behavior not not the
beacon of like
scared conservative
let's not mess up
let's not make it pathological it's not
make anybody angry let's it should be a
place to play in the space of ideas yes
so i think um the central problem is
actually related to the central problem
of covet policy more generally
the goal seems to be
to stop the disease from spreading
rather than to reduce the harm from the
disease
if the if the goal is to stop disease
and spreading the sad fact is we have no
technology to stop to accomplish that
at this point yes because like uh it's
already deeply integrated into the human
civilization well i mean it's here
forever right there's a zero survey of
white-tailed deer in the u.s it turns
out 80 percent of white-tailed deer in
the u.s have coveted antibodies
dogs get it cats get it
there's almost certainly human human
animal transmission of it um
i mean presumably i mean i've heard bats
get it apparently
so so you you have uh you have a
situation where you have this disease
that's here to stay yeah and it and the
vaccines don't stop the spread of it the
lockdowns don't stop spread it we have
no technology to stop the spread of it
um and so we're burning the earth trying
to stop do something that's impossible
rather than
working on what's possible
uh and so like you know like letting
regular college happen that's a great
good universities are a wonderful
invention
and it's contributed so much to society
to decide to shut it down
the universities should be fighting
tooth and nail to not be shut down not
the other way around yeah
whatever the mechanisms that uh results
in the universities doing that that's
probably this is me talking it probably
has to do with certain incentives for
the administration probably has to do
with lawyers and legal kinds of things
to
to avoid uh legal trouble but once again
it's when the administration has too
much power and too much uh definition of
what the policy is for the university
that's when you get into trouble the
beauty
the power of the university should be
about the faculty and the students
administration
just gets in the way
get out of the way i mean they can help
organize things they they play some
important role but they certainly do but
they need to remember what the mission
is the mission is not
safety the mission actually university
should be dangerous places you know for
ideas and and and whatnot
what is the role of fear in a pandemic
we've been dancing around it is it
useful is it destructive or is there
sort of a complicated story here because
uh instead of taking us back into
january 2020
there's so much uncertainty this could
have been a pandemic that
um
is black death the bubonic plague it
could have killed
hundreds of millions of people we don't
know that
we're we're very new to this it's been a
while we're rusty
so like there is there is some value to
fear so that you don't do the stupid
thing you don't just go on living i
guess where i come from i think it's
almost entirely counterproductive
i think fear should never be used as a
tactic to manipulate human behavior
by public health so the fear on the
individual level
that feeling of fear you should be very
hesitant about that feeling because it
could be easily manipulated by the
powerful exactly so i think um that fear
is natural
and it it uh it's not something that you
have to you have to nest you have to
stoke to get when the facts on the
ground suggest it
right uh in fact the tendency for humans
in the in the face of
threats from infects disease is to is to
exaggerate the fear in their own minds
of the being contaminated by the
environment and by others that's just
natural to humans
and
the role of public health is not
necessarily to eradicate the fear but
like obviously technological advances
can help eradicate the fear but like but
it's really to help manage that fear
and
and uh help people put the the sort of
incentives that come out of that to
useful things as opposed to harmful
things
what's happened in this pandemic is that
there's been a deliberate policy to
stoke the fear
to help make people think that the
disease is worse than it actually is
in survey after survey you see this
and that's been incredibly damaging so
young people
have readily given away their
willingness participating in regular
life
because a they fear covid more than they
ought
and b they feared that they're going to
harm the vulnerable
in their lives
you put those two together and you just
that you get this powerful demand for
lockdowns you see this all over the
world
broadly speaking you have a powerful
demand for rational policies irrational
policies because i would like to mention
the flip side of that
i've been saddened to see how much money
there is to be made
by the martyrs
the people
the conspiracy theorists
that tell you
you should be afraid of the government
you should be afraid of the man
it feels like fear is the problem i
think there's some guy that once said
something about we should be we should
fear fear itself
uh
he was a president or something i
vaguely remember that
so i i so i'm worried about both sides
here that well i just i think the
general principle is that should not be
a tool of public policy right
right the true the public policy should
attempt and public health policy in
particular should attempt to address
that fear
uh
it's not that you should
tell people lies of course not tell
people accurately what the risk is
give people tools that have evidence
that they can address their risk with
um
and level with people when we don't know
i think that is the right adult way for
to deal with this pandemic from public
health point of view and that's that is
not the policy we have followed instead
public health has intentionally stoked
the fear in order to gain compliance
with his edicts
and i think the consequence of that is
people distrust public health
what you're talking about the distrust
of government i think is a partly a
consequence of that that that movement
which is much smaller once upon a time
is much larger now
because of essentially people look at
what the what public health has done and
said i mean they've lied to me a whole
bunch of times a whole bunch of things
is the general sense and there are
consequences of that
we're going to have to work in public
health for a long time to try to regain
the trust of the public
throughout all of this you've been
inspiring to me to a lot of people
you've been
uh fearless
uh bold
in these kind of challenging the
policies
and not in in a martyr kind of way
because you're walking
the line gracefully and beautifully i
would say
and
looking at that
i think you're an inspiration to a lot
of young people so i have to ask what
advice would you give them
if they're thinking of going into
science if they're thinking of having an
impact in the world what advice would
you give them about
their career
and maybe about their life thinking
about somebody in high school maybe an
undergraduate college i'd say a few
things one is this is a wonderful
profession you have an opportunity to
improve the lives of so many and do it
by having fun
the kind of play we're talking about
it's an absolute privilege
to be able to work in this kind of area
um
uh and to young people looking to say
that that have
some gifts or desired for for this area
i say please you know
go for it like do serious science
broadly yeah i mean it could be it could
be i mean i'm not i don't have any gifts
in ai but like you know it could be your
buddy but you know or in health or or in
medicine or whatever whatever your gifts
lie develop them work hard and develop
them because it's worth it it's worth it
not just um
not just because you get some status but
because the the journey is fun
and the result is uh improvement to the
lives of so many so i think that that is
the encouragement i give i'd also say if
you're looking at this ugliness of this
debate that's happened over the pandemic
i i'd say to young people we need you to
come come in and help transform it many
of the people you see in this debate
that behave poorly
i actually forgive them i've done my
best to try
um
because
their act their many of them are acting
out of their own sense that they're that
they need to do good but they've but the
mistake they've made is is in in is in
this arrogance and this power but when
you come in remember that example as a
negative example and so that you when
you join the debate
you'll join it in a spirit of humility
in the spirit of trying to learn um
while keeping that that love of
that led you to enter the field in the
first place
and yeah
choose forgiveness versus like derision
[Music]
um
like the people that
you know have messed up like give them a
pass
because that's how
it feels like that's how improvement
starts funny i've been thinking this
it's like uh
i told you i'm christian right so like i
thought like god has given me many
opportunities to forgive people learn
learn to practice how to do that give
you a gift it's a very humbling thing i
guess
is there a
memory
from when you were young that was very
formative to you
so you just gave advice to some young
people is there something that stands
out to you that uh
a decision you made an event that
happened that made you the man you are
today
i actually grew up in a relatively poor
environment like i was born in india
and i moved when i was four
my dad had uh eight brothers and sisters
and my mom had four brothers and sisters
she uh grew up in the salomon in
calcutta
my dad his dad died when he was young
and he supported his family his kid his
brothers and sisters with university
scholarship money
came to the u.s and my dad worked
in a mcdonald's even though he's an
electrical engineer couldn't find a job
in 1971 and so he worked at mcdonald's
um we lived in a in a uh like this this
basically like this the housing port
like development uh in in in cambridge
this like this middle building of the
17th floor of this like housing
development
um
i mean i i think that was transformative
for me like i didn't realize so much at
the time how that experience of being
essentially like
poor lower middle class
what effect it had on my outlook
you mentioned to me offline that you
listened to a conversation that i had
with my dad what what impact did your
dad have in your life what uh what
memories do you have about him he was a
rocket scientist actually
he
helped design rocket guidance systems he
died when i was 20
and i still miss him to this day
and i think that
experience of seeing him
sacrifice
his hidden self for his family
a brilliant man but uh in many ways
frustrated with like the the his
opportunities in the world which
publicly would let him to come to the
u.s in the first place
that's
transformed that's had a transformative
effect on me and i wish i could tell him
that
looking back
do you
think about your own mortality do you
think about your death your dad is no
longer with us
you're the
the old wise sage
that represents it's funny
i've only
worried about death uh once in this
pandemic although i've had two of my
cousin
who was 73 and my my uncle was 74 die
in india during the pandemic and i
grieved them both from covid um
like the fear of covid really has only
hit me
only really literally once during this
it wasn't for me
and i recognized it's irrational so on
the eve of the santa clara county zero
prevalent study
um it was it was a really interesting
thing because so many people volunteered
to help
and um my my my daughter
who's 20 she was i guess was 19 at the
time and my wife also volunteered to
help with like various aspects of the
study and so the eve of the study they
were going to go out in public
and i didn't know what the death rate
was because we hadn't done the study
and i suspected it was lower than people
were saying but i didn't know
i knew
about the age gradient because i'd seen
the chinese data
and my my daughter is young but my wife
is my age
and i didn't know the death rate
and i couldn't sleep the night before
like what if i'm putting my family
my kid my daughter and my wife at risk
because of some some activity that i'm
doing
um it was kind of i don't know i mean it
was so worried about the well-being
and of others yeah when you look in the
mirror i if i die i die i mean like i
just it's not i again i'm christian so i
don't death is not the end for me uh i
believe um and so i don't i don't
particularly worried about my own death
but i i do
i mean i just i think we can't help but
we worry about the the well-being of our
loved ones
so
from the perspective of god then let me
ask you um
what do you think is the meaning of this
whole journey we're on what do you think
is the meaning of life
no it's very simple love one another
treat your neighbor as yourself
it's love yeah simple as that
well i'd love to see a little bit more
of that in this pandemic
it's an opportunity for the best
of our nature to shine it's so i've seen
some of the worst
um but i think some of that is just good
therapy and uh i'm hoping in the end
what we have here is uh is love at the
very least
make your dad proud with some
incredible rockets
that we're launching i think you get
along well with my dad lex
i definitely would
thank you so much this is an incredible
honor to talk to you jay he's been an
inspiration to so many people and keep
fighting the good fight thank you so
much for uh spending your valuable time
with me thank you for having me here
appreciate it
thanks for listening to this
conversation with jay about acaria to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you some words from alice
walker
the most common way people give up their
power is by thinking they don't have any
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time